Okay.
One other note I want to get to regarding
Donald Trump's Greenville, North Carolina,
a Mag a rally yesterday.
It wasn't just the send her back champ about
congresswoman Alano Mar that was notable at
yesterday's Trump rally in North Carolina.
Another thing that happened is that another
one of these protestors showed up with a picture
of Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein, and he
was very aggressively tossed out.
So that happened again yesterday.
But then there's a third notable incident
from yesterday's rally in North Carolina,
which was that Donald Trump started using
a KKK slogan, a Ku Klux Klan slogan from the
1960 seventies I believe it is.
And that slogan is love it or leave it.
And this was in relation to the four ethnic
minority, democratic congress, women a with
which Trump is feuding.
Take a listen.
They're always telling us how to run it, how
to do this, how do the, you know what if they
don't love it, tell them to leaving
[inaudible]
and now watch.
I'll go back to, no, no sir.
That was so controversial.
It's not just a historical KKK slogan in general.
This is specifically a historical North Carolina
KKK slogan, which is where Donald Trump was
for this rally.
The KKK used love it or leave it as a sort
of, um, uh, motto or slogan to fight Communism
and integration.
If you don't love segregation, if you don't
love capitalism, then uh, either, uh, leave
it or accept it.
That's basically the way it's going to have
to go.
And this was a common slogan on banners back
in the 1970s in North Carolina.
And once again, this is the type of dog whistle
that is a signal to people who recognize the
language to the white nationalists.
And it has very strongly coalesced white nationalists
under Donald Trump.
I interviewed Richard Spencer a couple of
years ago on the show, a outright white nationalist
leader and he said, listen, we understand
the limits of what Donald Trump is able to
say publicly, but we know the language and
we understand the signals that Trump has a
history of using these slogans with dirty
pasts.
America first is another that I believe he
even used during his inauguration, seemingly
innocuous with a very ugly past that we talked
about from the early 20th century in the United
States.
As I told you earlier this week, you have
to be ready for a very racist and xenophobic
2020 campaign and one element of being ready
is not to allow the right to do the shame
campaigns around those who allege racism.
I'm not going to Redo the entire story.
I did it earlier this week, but the right
has waged a very successful campaign whereby
they turn around allegations of racism on
those who are calling out the racism.
They say, why do you see race everywhere?
You are actually the racist or you can't really
know if someone is racist in their heart and
mind.
Therefore, you should never say that someone
is racist.
We cannot fall for it.
Okay?
I already mentioned that earlier this week
and so what we need to realize once again
is that this is a viable strategy for Trump
pointing out the reality of love it or leave
it of send her back and all of this stuff.
If we imagine we just have to show Republicans
the origins of these phrases and then they'll
see the light wrong.
This is a viable strategy for Donald Trump
and as disgusted as I am and as many of the
people in my audience are with the, go back
to your original country stuff, beloved, or
leave it the America first stuff.
Republicans are loving it, okay?
They're eating it up.
There's a new Ugov poll which asked people,
what do you think about Donald Trump's tweet
that these four congresswoman or however many
he was referring to should go back to their
quote, original countries.
Republicans love it.
Okay?
48% of Republicans think it was great.
16% of Republicans said it was good and 24%
of Republicans said it was okay.
This means that 88% of Republicans believe
that Donald Trump's tweets telling Americans
to go back to the original countries was acceptable
to some degree.
Now, in contrast, 87% of Democrats believe
that it was not okay for Trump to do that.
57% of independents also believed that this
was not okay.
So this is a culture war.
This is not a disagreement on policy.
This is not merely showing them the racist
is racist and xenophobic nature of what's
going on.
We increasingly are seeing all of the characteristics
of fascism building here, uh, as per Humberto
Eco at his 14 signs of fascism.
We've got powerful and continuing nationalism.
We have a disdain for recognizing human rights.
Look at what's going on with the caging of
kids at the border.
We have the scapegoating of enemies.
This includes these four Democratic Congress,
women, Democrats in general, Obama, foreigners,
s whole countries, whatever.
We've got delusions of military, so or, or
aspirations of demonstrating military suprep
supremacy, the parade with the tanks rampant
sexism.
Trump is accused of 15 or more sexual assaults
and rapes and boasts about his actions with
women controlling mass media.
Well, Trump is trying to, anyway, he has the
help of Fox, hasn't totally succeeded so far,
but he wants to end.
He has the stain for media, which is another
sign of fascism, an obsession with national
security.
We see this through his rhetoric on immigration.
We met to have a country, they're all against
us, all protect you sort of rhetoric, religion
and government becoming intertwined.
A, that one's sort of, they're a, Trump's
speaking to the march for life or the, that
anti abortion thing.
Uh, something that presidents don't, uh, always
do.
Corporate power being protected.
Obviously it's Donald Trump after all, labor
power being suppressed.
Absolutely.
A disdain for intellectuals and the arts.
Trump hasn't read a book maybe ever.
And we see constant disdain for culture and
a more, a, a sort of sophisticated literature
and thinking and philosophy.
Cronyism and corruption, of course, fraudulent
elections or claims of fraudulent elections
to suit the ego of the leader.
We absolutely have that.
And then there's an optional 15th sign of
Fascism willingness to lie, which I probably
don't have to talk too much about with you
today.
Let me know what you think about all of this,
including this as a viable campaign strategy
for Trump.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman and the show is
on [inaudible]
Twitter at David
Pakman show,